welcome to this video yes this is the
final video for the second gosh IAM of
memorial yeah this is a bit late as
already pretty much announced when I
released the video for around seven it
took a while to do round eight and nine
yeah the reason was or is that um I
played a very important match with my
team than the german league and
unfortunately we managed to tie our
final match which under the circumstance
was enough to getting promoted to the
second german league which is kind of a
sensation for our team because we on
paper are rather one of the yeah
mediocre or or yeah not very strong
teams in this league but we still
managed to promote so great great effort
of the team well what that meant that I
was completely busy on the weekend and
now I'm ready to do the final two rounds
let's get going and well I'll do both
rounds in this video so it will be
rather long ish but also I'm going to UM
not be so comprehensive on the games and
the sorting what at this time is
completely random meaning the order in
which the games are on my my notes my
piece of paper that I have to help me so
let's start with because otherwise I'm
losing track completely starting with
Kramnik with wide against Russia DeGraff
round eight of course first yeah I'm
going to do this sorting first round
eight then round nine but within the
round it's bit random ok we get going
with this opening Kramnik is playing his
son yeah night a 3g three system that is
going for regularly in recent months and
yes almost yeah Bishop g4 this is a very
solid set up here by mvl something that
is played rather often on all levels
it's a very healthy setup and
leads to well symbol of development yeah
we see like this black gets all the
pieces out nevertheless I have to admit
that I was never a huge fan of this
setup for black um due to the fact that
it always felt I mean I never really
knew what what my plan is right with
like well white has some more clear or
clearer ideas and we see what Kramnik is
doing him he goes a for first year okay
gaining some space on the queenside and
now night H form this is always
something that that bothers me in the
systems this Bishop I get sometimes a
bit satellite on the Kings side and
let's see him yeah this is coming here
with before 95 yeah I mean this is
probably objectively equal but I still
would prefer whitey a little bit note
that the Queen only one is doing a good
job here supporting the Queen side of
course it's nothing terribly bad for
black but I think kramnik certainly was
comfortable here yeah 96 check he traded
this and now is basically stating as
wide okay I've got the bishop pair what
what do you have you should be six to
attack the e4 pawn and f3 yeah f3 looks
a bit ugly but it's probably unavoidable
to play the main problem with this kind
of move is that it weakens the g3 pawn
and with it the King a little bit but it
doesn't seem that black has some
something great to a Tekkit in this
position the computer actually suggests
to attack the pawn on g3 with nine age
five but it's difficult it's a difficult
move move for a human to play after c3
the comp wants to play f6 and Bishop f7
and this night is without any any square
it's I mean it's it's there to be ready
for g4 night f4 @ nobody plays g4 and
what are you doing with your night own
age five in the long run computer says
this is equal I rather prefer what what
mvl is playing with
the drawback of that setup is so which
is if you go f six now in comparison to
the nine th five idea now the d 6 square
is it's more difficult to protect as
rook da di let's say I've go here in the
other situation with the night oh and h
five you might just play rook the aid
and cover the six and this is not
possible here yeah why does a little bit
better here still f6 I think was right
what well she is doing it goes f5 and
hmm this is very aggressive looking but
it ultimately seems to weaken black and
the problem is shown very quickly looked
you won and now he went F form yeah and
after f4 White has a very strong
transformation move the engine is
already giving wide a very big plus and
says that 94 is a relatively best
defense which already gives up a pawn
but also gives them yeah black some
activity maybe that was an interesting
idea to try to muddy the waters but it
is it is a very tricky position already
the thing is that after f4 which looks
totally logical there is a tactical idea
for white white can sacrifice the
exchange yeah I'm not sure of tactical
as the right word because the
justification is that white gets this
pawn and this pawn and this is a less
tactical more of a strategic
compensation we see that white has two
pawns of course for the exchange but
well excellent central control this
Bishop is not not well on g6 and the
knight on d5 is an excellent piece in
fact here the Frenchman already what did
you do he already took that right yeah I
wasn't sure if there wasn't immediate
move he already decided to to break the
structure by returning or giving
material himself yeah I have really
understand this decision you don't want
to give why this this big center
it's difficult maybe c5 was an
alternative trying to open up for the
rooks but why this batter now you can
also he can just take this yeah I know I
think it's very difficult for black
already those pawns are just very strong
and white has easy ideas a queen up to
activate and f5 in the right moment just
not very good yeah he took there and
then gave gave the exchange they're only
five which ultimately leads to no white
inserted those moves yeah leads to this
position where black is if we do account
blacks got four pawns why it's got six
points so why these two pawns up but
black has some control over the dark
squares whites king is feeling a little
bit uncomfortable it's quite typical
that hear the engines they just they
just take b7 and say white wins this is
the situation for a human player when
you when you sit there at the board you
probably see of course that you can take
on b7 there and you probably think
exactly the same what I just said well
the computer will probably take it and
win easily but for a human player this
is not easy to do as the Queen steps on
a on a light square and well yeah it
looks like it what about Luke d2 for
example yeah i was seeing exactly this
position when when the broadcast was on
and I was thinking okay what would i
play and i was i was thinking i would go
Queenie free yeah which is the move that
that covers the most dark square as yet
and then trying to try to convert the
pawns not grab an additional porn funny
thing is Queen III isn't isn't the best
move Queen B 7 is but Kramnik played
Queen you three so at least that I
wanted to play crown next move not the
best move but chrome legs move from
bridges in ninety-nine percent of the
cases pretty good so and it is a good
move it keeps a big advantage it's not
as killing as Queen B 7
but yeah it is if you look at quimby's
heaven black can try a bit but
ultimately white is defending ya hear
what is consolidating and never lets go
of his big advantage so it was perfectly
fine what what he did ya hear mvl give
her a piece there to get counter play
with the a porn but check ultimately
there was some check there was no chance
given to him jack yeah and after rupee
one he resigned yeah that was a somewhat
strange game with one key moment if we
go back I think that this f5 move is
probably really questionable after luke
t 1 it is difficult for black to get get
a decent position anymore the ninety
sixth fret here sorry my mouse again my
night d6 threat here for watches is
really problematic and difficult it's
really difficult for black maybe you
could have chicken and and go from there
but well it's really hard to 96 is a
threat you cannot move this porous
rookie as a seven is hanging black is
really certain surprisingly big big
problems here already so on f5 was
really a mistimed move okay let's go to
the next game this is mammadov Caruana
and we have a rillo PES with default so
Carolina was maybe speculating on this
line to happen again as mammadov had
played it before in a game um I have to
admit that I forget I think again it
gets Micky Adams it was ok so Bishop g4
Bishop e3 this is what he had played
before exactly that um but now kawana
Teague's and place
huh try to remember what what am I
playing him I think 95 right Knight a5
and c5 yeah okay okay well this was what
Kara wanna play this is a principled
alternative to to the night a 5c 5 idea
which was also what what Adams played I
think yeah d 5 after d5 we get an
entirely different position d 5 and
night jumps to you for this looks a
little bit like the open Spanish but the
difference to the open Spanish is that
black some peace formation is a bit more
active than he usually manages and this
is definitely enough form around
equality we get an interesting position
here really quickly um here here and now
um Mario is going for Luke c1 which is
interesting because it simply ignores an
idea of the if you want ignores an aid
idea of the move Queen to d7 this was an
idea and well now White has to take with
the Queen as Bishop takes Knight eggs
loses the house or let's say the center
which is enough yeah Queen has to take
ticks ticks yeah and this was allowed by
mammadov it wasn't necessary could have
played g4 for example to push the bishop
back but this is really interesting now
of course queen age three losses due to
Brooke c6 so cannot take on h3 what
about this move though interesting that
was a possibility but not good after
Queen see to bishop in 126 wide retains
a great position for the exchange yeah
something like this for example if we
check this now c7 is under attack and d5
is on the attack and well let's say
Bishop a five Bishop g5 Bishop bag and
some
like this this is a position where a
practical player clearly prefers white
because white has the big Center and all
the ideas where black is just sitting
there and cannot do much this is not
totally forced by the way white can also
think of other moves here but be sure
before it's pretty logical yeah this is
a nice position for white I think so it
was avoided by Kara wanna he went um
well he played I'm sorry he started with
the bishop more but now went 97 he
didn't grab the rook yeah Bishop e2 now
take sticks yeah and note that now h3 is
hanging it was taken for Luke c7 and
night f5 interesting double double edged
position and at first you think that it
looks it looks risky for for white white
skin looks quite open there's night age
form and ideas like that but why it has
got active pieces the bishop is always
attacking the porn and the rook is on
the sound rank Queen g5 that was a
necessary move activating the Queen and
looking at critical squares on the King
side yeah route d8 was played yeah let's
let's have a look there what about this
that looks good but after Bishop g5 we
see that black has no exceptionally good
move it is protected here and the rook
hangs on ad there's nothing special here
really um black can also try this move
but this is also answered by Bishop g5
yeah if we think about this kind of
thing yeah here i'd rather be wide yeah
with there with the central pawns and
the active rook on g7 yet it's quite
surprising the situation is not cleared
or luke the eighth is probably a good
move okay now e 6 was played very very
sharp move but white cannot really just
sit around and it is really funny now
because um
then the next couple of move seemed
rather force and it leads to an a very a
very nice finish of the game already 94
of steak Bishop t5 and well Bishop g5
doesn't that look kind of tricky yeah
what about rook takes d5 isn't as strong
it was played the funny thing is it only
leads to a draw it looks very strong
because of 93 but have a look at this
white is checking here intermediate move
King edge 8 yeah what's necessary yeah
this is check checkmate this is a mate
so like had to go to age 8 and now the
the funny thing is Queen takes t5s was
played check Knight f3 takes takes
Andrew pH and black as a queen up for a
rock and it looks like white is
completely open e where the King so it
really looks like there should be some
kind of checking sequence that wins for
black with there isn't the absolute is
no sequence of checks that does win
Ned's it's quite it's quite quite
remarkable the game ended with this with
this kind of Perpetual we will we will
see that Kara wanna try to try it the
best right you went it gave a couple of
checks and then went to the six and
first glance you think oh wow that is
great i have could i have protected this
rook if white cheeks Queen takes black
is safe yeah no nothing happening who
cannot come to e8 but the funny thing is
white has rook see to e7 yeah this is
great yeah it's just blocking this
threatening route gave aid again and
again it's just a draw it's it's really
really funny yeah so come on and now
decided to turn this game with the Jacka
this kind of Perpetual what we can check
is a way to continue with the Queen f7
yeah Brooke cheeks rookie takes eight
route is seven though and wide we'll
pick up this pawn so there
is absolutely nothing to be gained here
by black he's also having this back rank
problem so black cannot just play rupee
six to cover the pawn or something he
has to take care about the back rank
let's say something like this aqui
Andrew k5 coming there's absolutely
nothing to gain here for black it's just
a draw okay so next game it was a funny
funny draw it's a some drawers are
better than others okay um this next
game is Wesley so with white against
Magnus cards interesting measure of
course the young Filipino American
player against the world champion they
didn't play that often so it's um
interesting ok we have a English opening
and now 95 was played by by by Wesley
yeah here White has a wide choice it can
also play something like d 395 is
interesting though and black and again
now has a an interesting choice you can
move the bishop again maybe to see 5 or
can take the capture and 94 was Carla's
choice this is probably a more solid way
to play then putting the bishop on c5
it's not a huge difference blacks
overall approach to that it's very
classical and sound the next move
forever by white Wesley so we now took
on deform um that was a little bit
disappointing I thought I think it's a
bit more interesting here for wise to
play a move like 91 or not a move like
exactly 91 I know it looks a bit strange
to retreat but the ideas to kick the
[ __ ] the night away from before next
and then get the night back into play
this keeps a little bit more tension on
the board and more pieces it was a bit
more interesting but you took on deform
and when the Queen a form
not that this is bad it's just not not
so interesting to to to play and in
general that's a quite funny tendency if
you have positions that only have
bishops on two sides with bishops um
then really quite often it is a bit
boring I know it sounds a bit strange
but sometimes the Knights do inject life
into positions because they are that
that queer quirky pieces that that can
jump it's kind of it sounds strange but
quite often on a pure bishop position is
very static yeah because there is no
there is nothing nothing extraordinary
happening it's all kind of bit slow
ischium and this is also applying to
that game a five was played at e3 and b5
interesting way to play by Magna see
develops his bishops that way like this
it's not such a great idea so back and
now Bishop d7 yeah Black has gained a
bit of space here on the queenside and
can certainly be satisfied with the
outcome of the opening and now b3 was
played yeah white by the way had the
opportunity to take the porn went well
this is not a pretty sight black is
definitely welcoming that on one way to
play after that capture is it's just a
move like this to block the deep on and
then try to pick up the pawns one after
the other it's just very anesthetic way
to play mp3 is far more logical Queen g5
checking the d5 pawn and you know a
three back and we should be too yeah
black is attacking d5 and now is taking
taking the pawn it certainly fitting
value to with with Queen g5
take an e4 splayed yeah I'm sorry I
misread my my piece of paper here I was
thinking that this was played but this
is in fact not such a great idea if we
look at this here Blanc is definitely
more comfortable now with more space on
the queenside and this a free porn being
a target before as stronger Bishop back
and taking now this is the the stronger
way to play keeping those bishops on the
board c5 was played anyhow and green g6
yeah all in all black looks comfortable
here p 3 and a 4 yeah black has a bit
more space and some targets on the
queenside however there was never really
a situation where like him got to
something very substantial it looked a
bit threatening but the beep on here was
not was not so um so dangerous
ultimately yeah Bishop to a4 as an idea
but wyd defended precisely looks 824 I
know that before as hanging so black has
to take care of that and now deform yeah
that is the the last probably last
really interesting moment of the game
cards now went Bishop to b6 he could
have played Bishop e3 that was
interesting and after Bishop e3 white is
forced to give up the exchange with rook
be three but he still didn't play at him
Carson note that white cannot play this
this is not a good idea now be two gets
far too strong with Bishop see to being
then the main idea also Bishop c6 in
them in the game yeah he would have
taken them and we can look at this
position with the exchange but we have a
situation where everything is on one
side of the board and why its position
if you imagine that the the bishop would
come to this well anchored to a place on
the three
White has a very well coordinated
position one pawn for the exchange and
this happiness also big pony alike Queen
here Bishop p.m. I'm sorry to h3y it has
compensation for the exchange and I
think blacks winning chances are
basically zero this is why you played
Bishop b6 trying to keep it more
complicated yeah Bishop e3 age 6 now
making sure that you're not back
raincheck made it but here we had this
transformation with a little tactic damn
check check a couple of moves later not
sure when exactly here they agreed to a
draw that was a very correct draw I
think no side ever got got something
substantial black cards and looked a bit
more comfortable around around this
around this move Sam but ultimately
those resources with giving the
exchanger for the pawn should be enough
to draw the game so pretty pretty sound
and correct draw in that game okay let's
look at the next game now this is Adams
with white playing onigiri two players
who certainly did not do not enjoy that
tournament very much curium what's on
minus 1 and Adams was I think what's on
last place I think after on seven okay
so what do we get a Sicilian and an open
the sayin good stuff night off and 2 g-3
being played yeah g3 against the night
off that's not exactly the most exciting
move but it can lead to interesting
positions nevertheless and we will see
that in this game um blacks main choices
between e6 and e5 I'm Giri goes form is
six transposing to em
um ravening and the type of position
yeah i'm not perfect with favor ningun
but it's early in the day um e 5 is the
alternative this was for example played
by Kasparov in his son in his match that
was played against Nigel short yeah very
very nice metrum if you did not watch on
any of that it was some broadcasted live
by the san luis chess club and you also
will find it on the youtube channel 22
times 3 hours of kasparov with short
great stuff good to see those two
legends in action yeah this is what
Kasparov plate but he success of course
also possible yeah and we have all those
very normal looking moves ATM preparing
some b5 later Quincy seven th one that's
all I know that kind of stuff yeah now G
for this is also the reason why g3 is
not necessarily a boring variation it
just starts a little bit slow but why it
has aggressive ideas and this is one of
them yeah first getting short cancelled
King edge one and now push the the pawns
there on the Kings side this is a bit
comparable to the classical variation
with six Bishop e2 if we go back here
Bishop e2 that's also starting slow but
can get rather sharp later with white
pushing this g4 just as a later stage
yeah um I really I like those kind of
approaches by why they are not burning
bridges but still leading two to
interesting interesting games um yeah
give me now went h6 which is technically
a novelty um yeah I'm not an expert
about this but in general the move h6 is
something that is played quite often in
those structures one idea is that if
white goes g5 which is not a great idea
in this particular position property but
I want to show the idea of black takes
and Dwight inks black goes somewhere
then now he five is a very nice outpost
for black's pieces this is why the
insertion of the trade H and F porn is
helping black because why drew gives up
his control over you five this is one
idea to play h6 however it's of course
also a hook pawn upon that helps why to
open up lines in some in some cases it's
a very um double-edged decision to place
a to move however Queenie to NR g5 white
wants to prepare this properly yeah and
now give you went night before well it's
a risky decision than to to get this
night decentralized um I mean
decentralized is the wrong word and he's
looking at the sea to pawn but also
gives white the opportunity to get his
night back to deform rook c8 route d1
Quincy for Queen f3 yeah and now I'm we
come to the next couple of moves are key
for the whole game and I have to admit
that with my really limited time on this
weekend I couldn't totally figure out
what went wrong now for black um I
actually do question the movie five
already but i'm i'm not sure sure
completely it is it's really too
complicated that too complicated for
such a brief analysis that i did to be
to BM to be very really sure what was
what was wrong there yeah II five I
think this has two problems actually the
move that um Adams plate was putting
black under under quite a bit of
pressure night f5 that was but there
also was g5 and G fibers also proved
really tricky moved to play maybe it was
even even better the idea is that if we
take him
and black takes we have worked if or
with the tempo and let's say Queen Queen
goes back we take here this this is a
very annoying possibility it's very very
tricky very complicated um g5 was was
very interesting but night f5 also gave
black quite a bit of quite a bit of an
agenda yeah take stakes and now after
takes on f4 Group D for Queen back and
Bishop takes now Gary actually took on
c2 and after that he's definitely in
huge trouble um the comp wants to play
Quincy five and trying to defend like
that but after age for white is just
better there's no question about that
you can fight with deform yeah but white
is better with this g5 business coming
this is one point or one occasion where
the h6 move is really blowing blowing up
in your face a little bit yeah this was
played and after that I think blacks
lost look back a night before and now
aged form and you immediately see that
white has a strong attack with g5 but
what is not so apparent to to to the to
the human eyes then white is really
already winning there is there's
absolutely nothing to stop the attack
the big point is that after night h7
that was played wide now does not need
to play any preparatory moves he can
play g5 immediately an interesting line
was Queen c6 by the way trying to trade
Queens it's quite funny that besides the
side steps that I meant we need to is a
good move but white can also even trade
Queens that is not not bad at all if we
just want to show how problematic the
position is for black this kind of
situation a move like rook h2 intending
King up King up while my Mouse King up
Andrew cage one is basically deadly
yeah that's it's really really bad yeah
okay even night h7 and now the bad thing
is that why doesn't even need to waste a
move here he has two can play g5
immediately and this is exactly do to
them unprotected State of this night if
we look at this let's say and what was
my note yeah he actually Queen g3 but
this this was the funniest line and it's
a double attack it's a full complete
double attack both nights I hanging and
one is getting lost yeah this is a bit
different but Queen g3 is very strong
there's really a no defense against that
what was the line Queen g3 night h7 and
this going here and there's 94 what is
attacking with all pieces it's it's too
much yeah this is what he we tried but
then f6 was what's the decisive blow
pawn took yeah if black tries to
sacrifice him this kind of thing 94 is
one problem it's really it's really far
too dangerous attack yeah night here
night to d6 that was already possible
right away but this was hanging a check
so it's better to play this first yeah
white is smashing this is a position if
you give this to computer it's not just
like white is better as a plus 5y a
computer already calculates this is
crashing through yeah this was played
but now the open G file ism it's just
decisive yeah Adams and observe by
nature solid positional player but that
doesn't mean that he is not able to
attack if they if the opportunity is
there and he is really really doing a
good job here in destroying blacks
defenses here rube t6 is quite powerful
if the rook has taken
96 how do you defend here going back
okay look at the poor Queen ya head
that's not not ending well yeah this was
played Bishop age 6 it takes takes rook
c6 and now I by Queen g4 King here
Chattanooga h7 Geary resigned the game
after King takes Knight f6 cha cha is
going to get checkmated or in this case
loses the Queen for absolutely nothing
so a crushing victory here by micky
adams yeah and showing that a slowish
build up here can still lead to an
interesting attacking in taking game I
think um critical or what's the the
stage around here starting with night
before and Quincy for um another huge
fan of that but I'm really it's that's
not my type of position it's difficult
for me to to give a very educated
opinion on that i'm pretty sure that II
five was at least very risky move and
night take see to hear was was the loser
the losing move yeah the tough game for
44 Giri to be perfectly honest I'm if we
go back there I i really like you five
more hear that trying to to stop White's
in its tracks with any attacking
ambitions but that's not an objective
evaluation it's just my personal
preference i tend to prefer to have a
pawn they're only five to grab more
central space okay next game of this
round round end that i'm going to cover
is anand mahmoud yarn off assets and
also the final game of that around it is
right so i'm making good progress here
ok let's see what Anna did we have this
and the Petrov quite surprising but it
is part of Mammadyarov repertoire
doesn't play he didn't play it yet in
this event I think mostly because they
defiance but yeah let's say what we she
is doing us 93 okay interesting decision
not one of the main lines but certainly
a playable a player will move and I'm
actually it's interesting what we she is
doing that let's put it that way he goes
for the Spanish four nights and I always
thought that this is an area where white
can try a little bit I mean not that
this is great for white but they play
many lines in them in the entire Berlin
with d3 there are also just nothing for
white or very very very little and I
don't think that this is a huge
difference the Spanish four nights um in
terms of let's say ambition yeah if you
try in the in the entire Berlin why not
try here one point is of course that 94
is a move the Rubenstein variation this
can lead to shower play though it's not
boring at all but mamedyarov goes for
Bishop before and castles councils d3d 6
and now anand comes up with an
interesting choice the main Mafia is
Bishop g5 but that goes for 92 that's
interesting the idea is to get the
Spanish maneuver completed with Nigeria
and then place you free this position
type that we get because mamedyarov is
playing basically the same thing egg
brings the night over and now Bishop p6
this could easily happened out of an
antebellum but note that the night on g3
yeah the night on g3 very often it goes
there via here here and here and here
white didn't even have to play the move
look you want it is coming now anyway
but it's it's quite interesting it could
be that this position you could probably
construct some kind of move order to
make this happen from an entire Berlin
and show us that there are many
interesting
well interesting is a bit much it's not
like this leaves you jumping up in joy
in this kind of position but there are
some some some sidelines let's say that
are still leading two to full play this
is not a particularly boring position I
mean white has over both sides that
they're all pieces are on the board and
you can get an interesting game later I
don't want to look at all moves there I
think this is all fairly logical looking
at they connect rooks a five and now
interesting approach by Alan c4 yeah he
occupies the the center even more it
introduces the idea to play c5 if given
the opportunity yeah mama y are of
course a form rube t1 now he captured on
before Bishop takes yeah all this is I
think fatty fairly normal looking Bishop
c5 route you to an interesting little
effect is that here Bishop c5 at first
you think okay what about this isn't
this good for white yeah getting this
pawn structure here check with a double
pawn in fact this is a pretty well-known
pawn structure and it quite often arises
from a completely different opening from
the bogo Indian yeah it's actually a
structure that as sometimes have in my
own games in the boob indian however
white usually has fianchetto would what
here there is this information the
reason why black is ok here is that
those points are on light squares and
this means that the white bishop in
relation to the pawn cm isn't very very
great black also has this target there
and a weeks Rick square on d4 quite
often Queen can come to e5 or to F form
in this case even and the night might
have roots like here here
here n to d4 if everything falls into
place for black so this is not a
particularly great structure and was
avoided Banerjee just doubles on the D
file look T 2 night went back group t1
route 8 yeah here maybe instead of Route
28 and black should have thought about
simplifying a bit but I think why does a
bit more comfortable here in any case
just a little bit this was what I was
thinking maybe you can trade off a bit
and now go 95 yeah trading um is
probably not a bad idea so you have less
space but in any case let's say after
Bishop e2 group 28 and f4 white
certainly is a bit better f5 is one
important move to make sure that the
night is not coming to a really bad spot
this this and this yeah this is an
interesting and key line look 26 is a
mistake we will see something similar in
the game happening but here why does
especially suffering from the fact that
this night is unprotected so why
shouldn't take there but you can play
like f6 for example for an interesting
position queen here and sorry 94 Queen
here lead it leads to an interesting
game I think maybe maybe taking was an
option simplifying rook 28 now we see an
interesting move by V she goes night h4
and this is quite strong I think yeah he
avoids the trades and make sure a night
comes to f5 and this really keeps black
under under quite substantial pressure
like now trade it and when c5 of course
yeah get it try to get the control over
d4 you're weakening d5 but that's not a
not a huge deal the big point is however
what about this night rook takes the six
that was played and all 96 yeah at first
it's quite difficult to understand why
why could like give
the d6 pawn the idea is that 94 it's now
it's known absolute key resource this
she was playing this but let's have a
look there what happens if white is just
retreating the rook yeah trying to just
keep the pawn yeah the problem is that
after 94 Queen here Knight e5 black gets
really really nice compensation for the
pawn yeah what what about those nights
that's really great excellent excellent
pieces so um black has read compensation
yeah mission was playing that h2 f5 and
this is this is really strong the idea
is that after 94 he had now the move
Queen to d2 yeah this is protected
Knight e5 now yeah and why what about
this now what about this rook yeah isn't
this like forced to take 98 yeah but
have a look rook takes rook chicks and
what exactly this wide play now the
problem is that this is really awkward
yeah for oops this kind of threat if
white is taking here Luke takes note
that c4 is also under under pressure and
will probably fall yeah this is really
nothing for white so what did we see
play played group d 5 yeah remember he
had sacrificed and exchange earlier in
the game against Micky Adams and again
he does a desert here rook t5 just
putting the rook on a control square
yeah black took it okay pawn takes Queen
to be 6 yeah maybe Knight takes it to
was a bit more precise but it's probably
not a huge difference f 496 I want to
get to this position here we see that
White's compensation for the exchange is
really really nice he has this excellent
porn center and they're great night on
f5 so on a very very nice compensation
instead of 96 by the way black also
could have traded on YouTube we should
look at this briefly it was a pretty
decent alternative or a decent is wrong
with it was a an alternative to be
considered this is what I was trying to
say Queenie to check check and this is
what at first looking quite good when I
looked at it but then Queen g4 dawned on
me this is a bit strong what about but
this here you have to go g6 and after
this you're getting destroyed this is
looking nice on d3 but it's ultimately
just alone it doesn't really do anything
substantial yeah went back and Bishop c4
yeah Queen a5 Queen f2 and be 54
counterplay yeah night XD for Bishop e2
before that oh very it looks quite
logical and and now I think maybe a here
we can improve upon islands play and
note that the clock times doesn't make
any sense but mamedyarov didn't have
much time let's clear but he didn't lose
on time iam um uh not now played Knight
a5 very normal looking move but it seems
that f5 was very interesting and then
night age five with this Queen g3 idea
after the move in the game night f5 it
seems that mamedyarov is gang is gaining
quite some play but it's very tricky I
mean I really don't think that I'm I
analyzed this properly to be perfectly
honest I can show you some ideas but i'm
not completely completely sure but we
have to take into consideration that
they also didn't have much time to
analyze this position in the in the game
and it is it is ultimately a very very
complicated affair Queen c3 e5 I can
show you one key moment rupee aids and
now unplayed Queen Rock d2s brooke be
two waters Fred yeah here there are very
very interesting possibilities
Mammadyarov took on a three
which is probably probably too risky I'm
saying really probably because I'm not
totally sure d3 it was interesting this
is what I looked at a little bit the d3
move pushing the pawn and there I really
am crazy complications there for example
I can show you one line that that the
engine is giving its it's really really
funny 9 d 6 and if the black queen now
takes down one a three-wide can consider
the sacrifice to shop f7 Queen a7 check
this this is really really funny it it
looks super dangerous and after King six
now the move 93 white is just playing a
rope down but look at this attacking
idea see I like f5 yeah the black king
is completely completely out in the open
yeah the main line now is and all only
moves look be one check King up and not
be a queen before that is really the
only defense that black has look at f2
now I know it looks completely bizarre
yeah there are many things now I mean
black cannot take for example as maid
maid yeah and we are renewing the f5
idea yeah how does black defend against
that I really forgot that queen bee
seven and now wyd is getting stuff back
j5 check kingi seven yeah it has to be
played yeah this is check not ending
well ah now I screwed up the whole line
ah wrong wrong button yeah okay let's
let's do this again it's really too
crazy not to show yeah so check time
talk to this one and check here check
this is really have to queen bee seven
here exactly and now cry for create for
check quincy sex check again look listen
and now see sexy i look at those pawns
takes check check here
check and again and Queen takes g6
that's a completely crazy line that the
computer quite funny it is is a slightly
better for what yeah okay hmm yeah there
were many many crazy possibilities
playing this over the board is of course
murderous you just have to go with your
instincts and play something okay he
took on a 394 check King edge to what
I'm pretty sure about is that the next
move now is a mistake well brooke bc aid
was played but its move 40 you have to
play it and hope for the best um it's
the computer gives rupee seven is better
but i'm really unsure if it would have
helped the game probably not I think
maybe really Queen takes a three instead
of d3 what's the problem but I'm kind of
every unsure it is too complicated to
tell I mean if you if you're I said I
said there were the calm for about 10
minutes and with these positions and I
couldn't really come to a clear
conclusion i just showed one or two
things what i would have checked but
this is definitely losing after after d6
the tech now is too strong a three-night
f5 yet we have the ideas there on sorry
I'm a mouse yeah I looked at looked at
new ones but it's always it's a tricky
decision to buy a mouse i think there's
tons of things I mean tons of models and
it's well it it's in your hand all the
time and you have to really check what
fits your your hand and whatever it's
not so easy to buy one yeah have to bear
with me yeah well here really the attack
is too strong Luke f8 was played and
covering f7 and d7 now and after that
Mammadyarov resigned yeah after Luke cd8
there's Queen d4 intending ecigs and
it's impossible to stop that yeah align
that the engines is giving changing is
giving us
this with a quite quite funny position
why it is just winning one of the rooks
with this fork and they're still d7
alive which would probably promote as
well so great Winnie a forum for are not
in this penultimate route round which
got him within harbour point range of
the leading player of this event Magnus
Carlsen yeah let's get to the final
round then and as announced this video
is quite long but tied around can be
done a bit quicker after same let's go
with Mahmoud yarrow of atoms to players
who probably cannot be too satisfied
with the event they got I think one
winner near adams bead giri and
mamedyarov beat kramnik but they also
lost lost games so let's see we have a
queen's gambit and adams is going for
the classical line with Bishop e7 he's
not playing the rogozin and Mammadyarov
goes for Bishop g5 p.m. yeah um I think
he's one of the players who prefer
Bishop g5 most of the time compared to
Bishop f4 but in this game we see how
solid the Tartar cova is b68 artico
variation Bishop d3 Bishop e7 castles 97
italico ways what I usually recommend to
people if they tell me I'd like to play
in a solid wave black Queens gambit
declined is okay then I'm always
recommending the taaraq over because it
gets a pretty good balance between solid
game and still should some chances to do
something as black especially if you are
willing to take some strategic risks
then black can definitely play this type
of position with with some ambition you
have to take some risks though Bishop g3
and c5 takes here for example um if you
want to do something as black it's not
the best move but if you want to be more
ambitious you can take by the
on this is a bit better for white this
this hanging pawns type of positions but
it is interesting to play for black you
can you can expect together get a sharp
position later but Adams played 95 this
is the better move really but also the
little bit more boring move we have to
say look see one was played yet in the
recent game Nakamura with white against
Wesley so in the US Championships this
was played by Nakamura Queenie to and
after takes this was played right 90 x
we should have six look the one takes
takes we had in about equal position
yeah this was played by Mammadyarov 9 f
6 and now the capture yeah this is some
after a five now very very sound for
black guy you have the usually you can
go Queen to e7 blocking sorry about my
mouth blocking before so black is very
very very ok here night h5 and after
Bishop b5 now we got some trades and
takes Queen takes its blundering stuff
oh it's actually possible I wasn't
really seeing that the night hangs but
it just leads no way of course just
totally equal yeah but this was bet it's
a bit more interesting so check back
yeah here already a 90s g3 was possible
with the very equal ish position but
Adams went for some drinks and he moves
first now we took went back yeah the
thing is that this is opposite colored
bishops which is always not always sorry
that's a really the wrong word but often
is some increasing the chance for a draw
a shout come off of the game um dan why
does a bit more active with this rooks
but you create is coming nothing's
happening here in the game they actually
repeated quite quickly here with this
and now agreed to a draw yeah that was a
pretty boring game but you really AM
understand if you see that those
tournaments they are exhausting eight
rounds and this is a final-round they're
both didn't do well and well you can try
a little bit but if nothing's really
happening out of the opening a draw is
not not a particularly bad result ok the
next game is maybe I can adjust the
sorting a little bit further for the
final standings let's say if ok let's go
with Geary kramnik yeah i hear i have to
admit that i am made a practical
decision here about this game how to
present it this game is long really
really long it's 80 moves and i'm going
to show keep some key moments or one key
moment let's say because it's just too
long to cover I'm 8080 moves is a bit of
a stretch i will give you one little
piece of information about the opening
it's a catalan yeah Gary playing the
cattle earning and scrum next a bit
cheeky as Kramnik is the the Catalan
guru yeah I want to want to point out
this line the early Queen see to that
Giri is playing here this is an
interesting move I want to recommend for
white players if you play those kind of
openings this is not a very popular line
but quite interesting the idea is that
coverings you form um it's tempting
black into taking thinking that this is
the same thing as usual but that's not
the case after a six-year white has the
immediate Bishop f4 and with this attack
on c7 you really prevent beehive so this
is not the same thing why it has not
cancelled yet so Quincy to is
interesting the best reply to Quincy to
is c5 as kramnik plate in this in this
game and now white gets interesting
plane after this this this we have a
position here in the in the game that
very much looks like a goon felt with
reverse colors yeah the Queen on c2 and
this can easily happen from a
felt if you imagine just having it with
colors reversed I mean this is not an
advantage white but it's an interesting
twist how to how to play and this early
taking on c4 for example is a mistake
that's happening quite often it really
is not accurate white is getting a good
game there okay I I don't want to a set
cover this in so much detail we had an
equal ish position I think out of the
opening this miss Bishop is looking a
bit strange on a six but it's nothing
serious and did I make some notes
they're not really yeah we had this
transformation and to our chronic is
suffering a bit with his pawn structure
there and he never got in c4 so it looks
like why there's a bit better the the
real question is some about a little bit
later yeah instead of there was an
alternative there for five he Queens you
to look good to me it was i was a bit a
bit surprised that this was avoided by
Gary which seems to trade queens or push
blacks Queen bag and where this is not
looking too great white is better here
yeah he went night c4 and now Kramnik
gone in a while I was a bit surprised by
that that he hit that he allowed that um
yeah okay this is still a really long
long game ahead of us so I'm not going
to be very I'm not going to do this in
detail they trade it to this end game
yeah if you do account that it's equal
material but why does a bit more a bit
more active there against the Seaport
and so looks very drawers now well let's
get ahead now check now white was
getting some ground there on the King
side winning Paul but black hennessey
porn and it seems that check gear we
really got a nice advantage oxalic yeah
here with this pawn until got to see
porn ahead check check check
yeah those end games are touristy tricky
with the Knights chata like Heather and
tried a bit of checks check around this
this time is very interesting to look at
this position it's really complicated
but well as mentioned i had to make some
some shortcuts here for this video to
not make it two hours and i'm going to
concentrate on one particular situation
here this is happening check a couple of
moves later if you want to look at a
technical end game this is it yeah look
at look at the same game it's quite
quite interesting to try to calculate
here this is this is a key position yeah
we have to see that while the clock
chimes are not entirely correct there
but we are dealing now about a situation
where they have a an increment the 30
seconds I'm not sure might be 30 seconds
but they only get it after move 60 so
they were really down on time and this
is notoriously tricky as I said with the
Knights there and they had played eight
rounds before and so on here um Giri is
playing the move rook to or place the
move as someone recently pointed out to
me should say place and not is playing
yeah he plays or he played rook a form
um yeah and this it looks it looks
perfectly normal and getting this tempo
rook g4 looks quite strong but that
seems to be only drawing the move that
wins is root g 7 which is of course
brutally pointed out by the computer
rook g7 and it says plus five or
something yeah um the thing is that
after luke t seven black cannot stop the
porn after rook takes for example this
look there's king of eight and now the
point is promoting it's quite funny that
here here this is just winning checker
here black has no way the night is just
on a terrible spot it cannot stop
kicking
and.and f8 just impossible and why
didn't in any other case we'll just
promote with the pawn yeah so instead of
taking it can also go and no we're like
here go eat seven check very unfortunate
yeah that was the wing yeah it would
have been very nice for Geary and
probably deserved win after this I mean
this is always heartbreaking at you play
70 moves and then you play one num one
band move that it's not apparently I
mean it's not like you instantly see
that this is bad right it's just that
the other move is winning and this this
also looks very good but it's simply not
enough it does not win the night nor
fear is threatening this idea amongst
others jam it's not enough check really
it's not enough black gets this pawn and
when did they agree to draw check here
they did agree to a draw after king of
six I think yeah here they agree to a
draw the funny thing is that if white
tries to white is not what looking and
tries to play G Phi M you're even
getting check check even getting
checkmated yourself that would have been
well have would have been a holder yeah
but you know after seven games of seven
hours of playing all kinds of weird
things happening yeah the problem is if
you cannot play g4 how are you keeping
the pawn there you're not so a draw here
yeah disappointing for Gibby for sure
after this this long long struggle to
not get a win in but yeah they both
didn't have a great great tournament so
next game is mvl Maximus Telegraph with
wine against Wesley so and we have a
calc on okay
in five yeah this is what they almost
all play the advance and we get an
interesting variation here so is going
for a sharp sharp approach to this
opening well they quite often nowadays
play with without the early c5 they play
like night d 797 those slowish buildups
for example this is what what gear we
are played against are not earlier in
the event but this is the kind of this
is a sharpest way to play queen bee 62
396 yeah here in this particular
position we had a well-known game where
Russia lagrave was black actually
against um against kawana last year in
the in the same field cup in San Luis
this was part of kiwanis streak of winds
their car wanna play castles and won a
nice game but night a4 was played in
this game by maxim yeah this leads
pretty much by force to what we see now
queen 85 c 3 and the capture that is the
idea after those trades black gets a
little bit of relief there because of
the reduced materia account and he gets
97 c 6 in this idea what Queen B 6 Queen
a5 check is quite well known from the
French defense of course here we have
the bishop on f5 which is some young
looking looking good first side as usual
as in the CARICOM but sometimes you also
lose time with the bishop or you have
problems on the light squares this is
also what we see here this is a typical
way to try to exploit the bishop there
with their those porn pushes wide is
gaining lots of space yeah here knight
c6 was played and after castles we had
this
simplification yeah an interesting turn
of events Luke see one yeah note that in
this position black shouldn't try this
here yeah you can take the pond there
with check but well this is not yet
castled and sorry for my mouse again
White has this check in the mix let's
have a look there may be Queen d7 trying
to prevent Bishop b5 well have a look at
this f5 the bishop and e6 this is not
going to end well yeah let's say pigs
here and take him check this is a huge
threat a huge threat white is winning
here quite quite quickly yeah so this
was not possible black could not take
the pawn castles was played roop takes
Queen d7 yeah and this first glance
looks really nice for wider he's got a
huge advantage in space and he's quicker
on the C file um in win the game let's
have a look what happened in the game
here here I was a bit surprised that
when we got this here we had this
position check check yeah I was really
thinking that this should be really good
for white but it's in the game let's
have a look what happened here this this
kind of position it looks overwhelming
for wider you're controlling the
seventh-ranked and I mean I was thinking
isn't this just possible to bring the
King up here and win with the a porn
what is black doing him it's quite
interesting if we look at this rooks e7
I don't know why it was why was this
necessary if you go King f3 I didn't
look at this game too much as I was
bishop c2 I see
the counter play okay so this is why you
went here to prevent Bishop see to
Bishop f3h three look a five rook a 5 mm
okay Roxy one age five and now he he
captured am the thing is that might
sponsor arbitro neural maybe g5 was more
interesting I mean white only has to get
the king over them and he will win the
game oh maybe g5 after this capture here
black got this and now you always have
this counter play yeah I'm not sure
maybe maybe black is still ok down but
it looked very tricky would be surprised
if some deeper analysis um gives gives
white something in the in the game we
got this repetition and now e5 opening
up for activation of the king and
trading down to a rook endgame and this
is really just a drawing blood get this
back I think they even traded saturated
those pawns there yet here they agree to
a draw yeah it was that was probably
probably there was something for white I
neglected this game a little bit have to
have to say now that I see my notes it
seems like I didn't really look at this
very much but then the question is if
around here and if there is some
improvement for wide it really looks
like there should be something I would
be really surprised if what if this is
just a draw so I mean this cannot really
believe it maybe g fire kind of curious
him what about this i had to go here
again
okay well this is not possible here and
now if you do hear a bishop you ain't ya
hmm most look and games wouldn't be a
problem but this one might be a because
of the week dark squares there is this
this route that looks sorry again for
the mouse and it looks tricky somewhere
around here there must have been
something forever she would be really
really not okay let's have a look at
Adams sorry against the car wanna Anand
well I print out here it gets very
confusing let's let's do this yeah so
Allen was was trailing cars by have a
point so win with black against karana
would have been great of course but well
not easy to do it's also a little bit
about the the ranking spot in the in the
in the in the in the top top a low
rating list of course cards and is
leading by a mile but the second place
is actually very very contested and
Anand is on second place at the moment
before this game I mean and with the
draw he will keep the second place with
the winner of course as well and kawana
where the wind would take over second
place so let's see what we get yeah
again the slowest opening but as I said
quite often it delays the fight are not
just going for this classical set up
with Bishop to d7 ready to play a
Catalan or also play the black side our
Kings in unitech c4 castles yeah d for
now leads to the main line Catalan but
Kara wanna goes for be three this is
again a case where the slower looking
movers actually the more aggressive one
b3 is some more interesting in
comparison as it keeps more pieces on
the board it has
interesting attacking ideas we see some
of those ideas in the game I have some
experience with this kind of position
with white and this is one of the ideas
an early night h4 and this is really
really early um quite often i played
this position with later 91 but it has
the same idea the idea is to clear I'm
sorry to clear the F pawn to advance and
this is really quite annoying for black
off interface yeah you can even
sometimes push g4y it is trying for King
side attack we have this straight 98
yeah eyeing this night f4 yeah note that
black is really absolutely not in a
hurry to take the night if we look about
this look look at this this is actually
opening up the G file for ym note that
this is strong bishop and ultimately
there will appear rook on g1 or g3 or
something and it's not a great idea to
take the night this was played night
takes and now f5 is an idea to get the
night back into play this is a pretty
rare way to play this opening with with
f5 and night f4 but it's something that
I played myself i played this some only
it was about two years ago I think in
the tournament game which I
unfortunately lost with white but it was
quite interesting this this this way of
handling the opening here the night
comes comes there you have ideas yeah
night h5 sometimes you can get in d3 and
94 it's quite quite an interesting
position 97 d 3 and this very radical
solution but but a good one you don't
really quite often see this just taking
with a at least from from a purely
optical point of view good bishop
against a night but the night coming to
e4 was a very annoying prospect so just
taking it
and shutting down the diagonal was a
good idea yeah Corona went to h3 keeping
this on the board 926 check they traded
created in tonight dat re-routing to c6
the edits all very very sound and solid
and simply put drive after this they
played a couple of more moves it's not
that they immediately agree to a draw
but there is really little to play for
what white looks like a miniscule little
bit better but it's it's really nothing
serious yeah this guy gets shut down and
also here when did they agree to it
wrong and they repeat it and then then
agree to a draw yeah there's really no
way forward the position is it's just
too closed nothing happening so koala
tried here with this reti opening trying
to do something with many pieces on the
board but it seemed like we she defended
precisely so um unless Carlton is losing
his final round game he will win this
event and we will look at cars and
scheme now and it means that Anna is the
number two player in the in the upcoming
rating list for May May first which is
really great right i mean if you're a
fan of him or not but being 45 years old
and being the number two player in the
world again I mean people really were
screaming he should retire after the
2013 World Championship match and he
simply didn't he got a second match
against Magnus by winning the candidates
and now he's the number two rated
players just great okay let's see the
final round game their cards and with
white against Mahmud off the local
number two player and where
notes here now ya Mahmud of having a
very solid event he played seven drawers
lost one game but now he has to play
black against the world champion in the
final round it's not the easiest of
tasks ok what do we get we get a sloth
by trans position with Bishop f5 we had
this earlier in the event um I think it
was what this Mahmoud yarra off with
black I'm not quite sure we had this
earlier in the vent is this precise line
and I am mentioned some some details
there I am not quite sure what the
precise pairing was ok but we can look
at this here rookie one yeah this is
identical by the way to the game counts
Nakamura of the Sham Kia tournament last
year exactly one year ago in this in
this game back then Nakamura went for
bishops III you just took the night
there um yeah Mammadov plays Bishop to
a5 just protecting the bishop by
retreating it why protecting it the
thing is that if you play the normal
looking Newsnight b7 this is really a
surprising mistake as ninety five wins
the pot it looks strange why does this
win a point yeah ninety-five cd5 and now
we have this situation black takes and
now d take these six the night years
hanging intermediate moves d take c 6
and this Nets white upon at the end yeah
Bishop f5 takes and watches on this
level basically winning it's a pawn and
a big center so that's it so night BTW
seven is a big mistake so black has to
do something but what exactly it's not
not clear as I said Nakamura to console
three
Bishop a five and now a for was played
gaining some space and preparing the
upcoming move before interesting the
same idea but this time it's not winning
material as after what did you do he
takes Bishop takes you can take play
rook e8 yeah well and it's not winning
material because before gave away a pawn
in the first place however now after a
five why this retaining um certainly a
certain position positional advantage
simply because of the b6 pawn I sorry
the b7 pawn it's backward on the B file
and when you move it the a porn would
always trade trade against it so this is
a very nice position for white
definitely a good opening result form
for the world champion and um this is a
kind of position where you have to be
patient and white and sit on it for a
while yeah just trying to improve slowly
and we did that as usual he's very very
good at those kind of positions yeah
bishop before this is trading a bit but
the bishop only one wasn't wasn't a
great piece 94 and 95 trading nights as
well yeah okay black takes context and
now we have a situation where of course
no long term only white can be better as
those two points are stopping free porns
have a black on them on the King side
and check here and Queen f7 was played
white will always be better here but the
question is can you win the game this is
really am also not clear to me to before
the honors white is better but is it
something that can be can be transformed
into wind ultimately Queen g4 try and
form Luke to t7 f5 he certainly wanted
to provoke that weakness look for
27 check check and Luke invaded here on
d6 yeah and now this is this is
precisely the critical position mammadov
defended this this quite well up to this
point and he had yeah the icc clock here
showing 9 minutes which is probably not
totally precise but it's usually the
ballpark is it's right yes he maybe had
maybe had eight or ten minutes or so but
he certainly wasn't down two seconds or
something like that and now in fact he's
playing the decisive mistake just just
like that um which basically gives the
game away it's very unclear if if White
has does have anything substantial EF
black is playing them playing a better
for example if you just play let's say
you play rupee sorry not that one my
mouse again play rookie high if let's
say I just just staying and not not
doing very much it's how is right going
to win of course he's always claiming
had two pawns stop war tops top three
but these are also unprotected or let's
say they are a bit weak and I don't I
don't don't really see how wide is going
to go into wynia and say go here but
again the black is just just staying
there can always take the pawn I'm not
sure I mean white can certainly claim
slight edge simply because of the
structural advantages but can he win
it's very very difficult to believe yeah
he played Queenie five and well cars
just went here and now Mammadov resigned
as simple as that the problem is some is
this Queen g6 Queen g6 check and rook d8
and that's it you have absolutely no
defense g6 how do you protect g6 it's
over the Queen e5 was really a
take big blunder yeah the only thing
that black can do to prevent them the
immediate loss of everything let's say
is a queen move back and somewhere here
and then why it takes this was Czech
King back and now yeah whatever this is
a total win now I would without they
have fun it's totally winning white can
play whatever and he dominates yeah
black has no way to free himself what
can just push King side up quite quite
quite easily white white is a white is
totally winning yeah so disappointing
finish for Mamedov he really defended
well against the world champion but then
gave it away with her yeah more or less
one move blunder here in this in this
final round on the other hand Carlton
had a great result he got to an almost
3000 performance rating in this event
yeah he has one or two of those already
in his in his career but this was one of
the finest performances that he that he
put together close to 3000 performance
is simply am outlandishly hi um yeah in
term he gained a couple of rating points
putting his distance to number two which
is now wish Island to more than 70
points which is quite a quite a bit at
that level I mean if you mean 70 points
to put this into perspective if you
don't know the the ELO rating system too
well I mean for him to lose 70 points he
would actually let me let me calculate
that a little bit he has to lose about
let's say if he would play a match
against on again and you want cause and
to lose 70 points he would need to lose
about 12 games in a row to lose 70
points 12 games in a row and this is
quite unbelievable that this this ever
happens did I calculate that right now I
losses about six points per game his
expectancy is about six lose about six
points per game so maybe
let's lose 10 games or something but but
really really a lot 70 points at that
level is really really much really a big
distance yeah so a great great event
here for the world champion second place
for Vicki Allen and also second place in
them in the world rankings um yeah what
what else kawana had a decent event I
think it wasn't he expects more of
himself a guess but it was was quite
quite decent and we had many players on
on- to like Kramnik for example who
certainly was disappointed and he also
said that he's not planning to retire
from chess so he the only cancer this is
grant what it is called I don't this is
this grant world tour of chassis those
three big events he cancelled that due
to other commitments he's not planning
to retire and it's a good thing i really
i really think that if they people enjoy
chairs and chrome lik is a great player
so why why would you retire same for for
nadia is he's still able to really play
great chess so and those old young
clashes are really really interesting to
watch yeah when you watched Kasparov
playing on the on the weekend yeah of
course it just blitzen rapid but he
still he's still pretty good right would
be great to see him play more of those
exhibition matches but as he said in his
interview after the match he wouldn't be
able to him to really perform well
against the the super top players of
today and I think he's probably
realistic about that but he certainly
can put up a fight and pretty pretty
sure about that ok I hope you enjoyed
the coverage of that event been a long
video this final one but it was about
two rounds and I really was very brief
on some of the games sorry if you were
if you're a fan of a particular play and
those games were a bit bit short and
coverage but you have to cut some some
corners yeah thanks for watching and
yeah this is released on on a monday so
i've got a monday live show in if you
watch it exactly on the release
release date make sure to watch that as
well thanks guys by him